la parole est à notre collègue elisabeth
lamure pour deux minutes
les deux minutes reviennent à voeux
pieux mais je vous préviens en janvier
crack dans voilà alors j s merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'économie et
des finances monsieur le ministre à
l'insee vient d'annoncer que la
croissance française n'atteindrait que
1,2 pour cent en 2016 c'est
malheureusement très en-deça de vos
prévisions
cette croissance illustre le décalage
entre la france et ses voisins européens
car c'est 1,2 pour la france mais c'est
1 7% pour l'ensemble de la zone euro et
1,9 pour l'allemagne monsieur le
ministre comment expliquez-vous le
décrochage général de la france constaté
par tous les organismes officiels
internationaux
nous avons un taux de prélèvements
obligatoires qui atteindra 44 et demi
pour cent du pib en 2016
notre déficit budgétaire et de 3,6 cette
année soit 970 milliards la dette
publique
avec 2200 milliards d'euros atteindra
bientôt 100 % du pib cette dette a
progressé de 15% en france au cours de
ces dernières années
quand celle de l'allemagne reculé de 10
autant de chiffres qui montrent que vos
choix en matière économique ont fait
reculer le pays
pourquoi des pays comme l'allemagne
l'espagne ou l'irlande ont réussi à
résorber leur chômage quand le nôtre
continuer d'augmenter
monsieur le ministre êtes vous conscient
de l'ampleur de l'échec de votre
politique
à part l'état madame martine pinville
secrétaire d'état madame la ministre
avait la parole merci monsieur le
président madame la sénatrice j'ai
écouté attentivement votre question et
je vais vous donner quelques chiffres 1
c'est précis également la reprise de
l'activité économique dont vous semblez
douter se confirme depuis un an et demi
après une croissance après une
croissance de l'ordre de 0,5 pour cent
entre 2012 et 2014 l'activité croît
désormais un rythme compris entre 1,2 et
1,5 pour cent depuis l'année dernière et
vous devriez en être ravis cette reprise
est portée par la croissance de
l'investissement et la consommation des
ménages qui progresse nettement
et par ailleurs on peut aussi noter la
franche reprise du marché immobilier
qu'il se confirme après avoir
négativement peser sur la croissance au
début du quinquennat pour 2017 les
dernières enquêtes de conjoncture tant
du côté de la confiance des ménages que
de celle des chefs d'entreprise se situe
également à des niveaux très élevés
historiquement associées avec une
croissance trimestrielle de l'ordre de
0,4 à 0,5 pour cent tout indique donc
que la croissance s'accélérera l'an
prochain surtout l'économie créer à
nouveau des emplois dans le secteur
marchand à un rythme élevé ce sont plus
de 180 mille emplois sur une année cela
nous permet de revenir à un niveau
d'emplois marchands que nous n'avions
plus connus depuis 2009 il est donc faux
de dire madame la sénatrice que
l'économie française décroche depuis
2008 nous avons connu une croissance
totale de notre pi par habitant
supérieur à celle de la zone euro si
notre reprise a été légèrement plus
faible que chez nos voisins c'est tout
dernières années c'est principalement
car nous avons mieux résisté que les
autres
au plus fort de la crise vont conclure
se place dans un ton plus long notre
pipe à eau tant cru en france qu'en
allemagne depuis le début des années
2000 le président de la république et le
gouvernement ont tout mis en oeuvre pour
redresser le pays et nous avons nous en
voyons là les résultats
si madame la mûre madame la ministre
votre réponse est peu convaincante et
cache mal en réalité votre embarras car
les chiffres ont parlé et ce sont bien
les chiffres d'aujourd'hui qui atteste
du décrochage de la france et or matière
de décrochage en réalité je crois que
c'est votre gouvernement qui depuis des
années des croches et c'est ce
quinquennat qui fait du mal à la france
merci la parole et monsieur jean-yves
raude onge a eu des mâles